hello and welcome back to another video
today's video is about noblies which is
one of the most famous manowas that has
managed to grab the attention of geeks
all over the world as you've probably
guessed by now today we're going to be
talking about the two ova episodes of
novelis that were released in 2015 and
2016. the plot of knobley's ova episode
serves as a prequel to the original
series that released in 2020. the main
plot explores the reason behind the long
hibernation of the protagonist ryzel and
his awakening after several hundreds of
years in the human world these ova
episodes also feature the dark side of
nobles and humans that drag the world
into never-ending chaos well then should
we begin
humans have always been considered weak
and fragile creatures that need
protection from others and even each
other however luckily some beings with
supreme supernatural powers exist to
assist humans in every dire situation
these beings were referred to as gods
kings and nobles by humans the sole
purpose of nobles was to protect mankind
and the world from chaos according to
the legend amongst the nobles there was
a nobleese a powerful individual
shrouded in mystery named ryzel he had a
calm and quiet personality ryzel
maintained the peace of both worlds
through his overwhelming powers however
he decided to ignore the rampaging war
in the human world as the interference
of nobles only provoked more chaos the
humans shed the blood of their own kin
in the lust for power and dominance
ryzel spent his lonely days in the
castle of the noble world he had a
servant named frankenstein who had
acknowledged ryzel as his eternal master
the cold days in the life of ryzel began
to change upon his meeting with muzaka
he was the lord of werewolves and the
strongest noble alive in the world
musaka was a kind noble with a caring
personality he became rizelle's first
known friend after hanging out with him
for several years however at a point in
time he left the noble world for reasons
unknown and disappeared from the sight
of ryzel several years later he again
made an appearance in the castle of
ryzel while discussing this muzaka took
reizel to the human world and introduced
him to ashleen a young cute girl living
with him the war started by the cruel
humans and devoured ashlane's mother she
was left an orphan as an example of the
horrors of war musaka told reizel that
ashlyn's mother was his friend he
grieved over the fact that he couldn't
save the life of ashleen's mother but he
swore to protect ashley into the ends of
this world musaka was saved by ashlin
because he was going through despair but
her efforts had made him a kind man
ryzel departed with a smile while
acknowledging the change of heart of his
old friend on the other hand corrupt
nobles decided to use this opportunity
to get rid of muzaka while creating a
situation in which ryzel would be forced
into a deep slumber the clan of
werewolves and corrupt nobles joined
hands with greedy humans to start their
ultimate plan muzaka and ashley moved
into the depths of the northern
mountains to escape the flames of war
however the nobles dispatched werewolves
and human soldiers to the northern
region and their sole target was ashley
ryzel hurried to the human world to save
them from the impending doom the soldier
attacked ashley but she fought with
bravery and stole a horse to escape the
werewolf soldiers at the crossbow and
pierced the arrow through her heart
putting an end to her life
when rizal reached the northern ground
muzaka was crying while holding the dead
ashley he decided to end the existence
of humans who stole everything from him
he ventured towards the human town but
ryzel stopped him asking him to calm his
rage muzaka's rage had reached the
limits as mere words no longer affected
him a furious battle between muzaka and
ryzel started just what the nobles
wanted the whole situation was a tragedy
created by the evil nobles they knew
ryzel always acted rationally as he held
the role of nob lease and would
definitely stop the destruction of
humans and nobles he preferred peace
over war but he had no choice left now
muzaka attacked ryzel with his powerful
claws forcing ryzel to use blood
techniques when ryzel strangled him with
blood technique muzaka told him another
tragic truth about the real identity of
ashley the cute young girl was his
daughter and her mother was musaka's
love of life rizer was shocked to hear
about this and blood tears began to flow
through his eyes as he couldn't do
anything for his only friend and now he
had to take the life of muzaka to free
him from his overwhelming rage
ryzel ended up using his ultimate
technique bloodfield and awakening to
free musaka from rage the technique
drained a lot of energy and vitality
from ryzel forcing him to enter a deep
sleep in his coffin the entire area got
destroyed by ryzel's power leaving
nothing behind the coffin of ryzel
settled in the depths of the ocean but
this wasn't the end for him you should
never try to end the movie without
checking for the post-credits scenes so
in the post-credits scene a diving man
found ryzel's coffin in the deep ocean
and was shocked to see it this was the
main plot of what happened in the first
ova now let's talk about the second ova
nobley's awakening this episode features
the 21st century of the human world
where everything has become advanced
because of high-end technology and
progress in science however evil people
and organizations still operate behind
calm and prosperous cities an evil
organization has made several agents
with supernatural abilities by
conducting forbidden and immoral
experiments the organization has been
looking for the nobles rizelle to
harness his powers for their own benefit
and surprise surprise a government
organization has discovered the coffin
of ryzel while exploring the depths of
the ocean as we saw in the previous
episode however ryzel suddenly wakes up
and leaves the place before the
organization could catch him reizel goes
to yi ran high school to meet his
servant frankenstein who has now become
the principal of this academy ryzel
wasn't used to the technology of this
era and was surprised by the innovation
frankenstein welcomes the return of his
master and has him enrolled in the
school as a student so that ryzel can
become familiar with the new world all
the girls of the class were head over
heels for ryzel when they witnessed his
charisma and looks i wouldn't know
anything about that ryzel met xinwu a
straightforward guy with a strong
physique he and his friends became
accustomed to rhizel and decided to
become his allies through a series of
events on the other hand the
organization dispatched agents m21 and
m24 to find nob lease and bring him to
them m21 and m24 were failed experiments
they decided to betray the organization
and use the abilities of noblies to free
themselves however two powerful agents
of the organization mary and jake caught
them and decided to use them for a
little bit longer jake was a crazy
superhuman obsessed with killing people
here and there basically like an evil
hulk while mary was an intelligent
assassin tasked with accompanying and
assisting jake on his mission as ryzel
and his friends walk home yoona is
attacked by a zombie shinwu arrives in
time to rescue her ryzer observes the
strange guy but leaves as he's pulled
away by shinwu the two agents decide to
kill ryzel and his friends as they
witness the crimes and operation of the
organization unintentionally they kidnap
his friends and took them to a hidden
facility here jake tortured shinwu and
beat him up badly they messaged the
principal of the academy frankenstein to
lure ryzel out despite being heavily
injured shinwu struggled to protect his
friends upon seeing this m24 got
flashbacks of his days at the experiment
facility when his friend sacrificed his
life to save him driven by past regrets
m24 attacked jake despite knowing he
would be killed in an instant m24
exploded himself to protect the children
unfortunately this moment didn't affect
jake and he was still standing strong
frankenstein and ryzel eventually
reached the facility where mary and m21
were fighting ryzel orders frankenstein
to fight mary so that he could focus on
saving his friends frankenstein
dominated the battle in the beginning
but mary revealed her true form and
began to fight back ryzer orders
frankenstein to release his seal and
fight in full power frankenstein
unlocked his sealed powers and killed
mary in an instant this was no doubt
truly a badass moment on the other hand
ryzel confronts jake who mocked him
rizzo used his mind control technique
and ordered him to kneel before him
while being humiliated jake revealed his
true form in fury and madness but even
then ryzel forced him to kneel again
while ryzel uses his power to make his
friend sleep jake tries to hit him but
without success then ryzel touches
jake's blood to create a bloodfield and
tore jake apart leaving the building
with a bloody rainfall in the end he
used his abilities to erase the memories
of his friends to protect them from any
future harm so that's it for today as
mentioned before these are prequels so
if you want to see what happens after
just watch the original series from 2020
we hope you enjoyed it as much as we
enjoyed making it make sure you like the
video and hit that subscribe button to
get a notification of our future videos